All right. Hey, what's going on?
It's bill burr and this is once again
time for a very special Monday morning
podcast. A, you got an extra one this
week. And as always, whenever I do that,
you know, it's not just going
to be me running my mouth.
I always have a great guest and
this time is no exception. Uh,
please welcome for the multitalented,
the multi a business owning a from
a entourage. Jerry Ferrara, man,
I don't think there's any way I
could live up to that incident.
He talks about the game. You'll
one of the guys that like, uh,
when I found out you won't you at will
co owner of that fat Soule yeah. Uh,
which is as great a
sandwich place out here. Um,
one I found out that you were one of
the co owners. I was telling my wife,
I'm like, see, that's what
most artists don't do.
They have all their eggs in one basket.
I love the fact that you're making money
outside of this fucked up business.
So I joke with my brother all the time
and it's like I hope one day when I'm in
my sixties you look back like you
know acting was great, we did great,
but you know what, we really
killed us sandwiches. That's how I,
you know I ate there,
I ate there.
Cause the your slogan is that as soon
as sounds in and underneath that it says
we'll making sandwiches.
Oh my God,
the guy's of date when they hear it as
the guys at fat Sal's are going to die.
They had, they're proud of that slogan.
No, I laugh when we, me and my wife saw,
we laughed. We were like,
we got to try that place.
So of course I tried it
out and it's awesome.
But I'm 46 so I can only
eat there so often. The,
I close my eyes when I drive past
some filing, want to look at,
cause it's on the way to the gym.
So it's like I drive home,
I got a pass and everyday I'm like you
just worked out. Don't blow it. Yeah,
it's on Fountain on Fountain.
Then you've got the big flat screen
TVs or he's got the game on. It's,
it's unreal.
It's like a,
for someone like me that's
literally a moth going to the light.
But the reason your here is um,
you actually,
you have a new podcast coming out called
a bad for bad for business. Yeah. It's a,
it's three weeks old and hit as bad for
business because I really don't know
what the hell I'm doing.
I've, I've, I didn't know,
I didn't know what the Hell
I've been listening to to you.
Obviously for awhile now and I've,
I grew up listening to sports talk radio.
I didn't have a TV in my room, so
like a radio was all, I had stern,
all those things. So I just have had
an affinity for radio my whole life.
Where did you grow up? Bensonhurst.
Brooklyn. So, uh, all right. Oh God.
What sport affiliations
are you [inaudible] here
we you want to know? Well,
you know Nick's obviously
no problem with that.
We saw that the next Guy Yankees. Hey
you, why you made the right choice.
Could you say now though? You can't
even really say anything anymore.
What could you say you w what do you
mean by that, Jerry? You're golden.
You're good. Oh, I thought
you were going to say that.
We're doing exactly what the fuck you
guys were doing with buying up everybody.
I don't think so. I don't think
so. Ah, Yankee we did. We didn't,
uh Oh seven and look,
the minute seven was a disgrace.
The minute we gave Jacoby Ellsbury money,
the it to me,
it's over the rivalry's over the minute.
It started with Damien a little bit
like that was the Yankee sign. Damon.
It kinda ruined the whole the whole day.
Always go your way though.
They never come our way there. We
sell throughout my life. I'll be
back to guys like Bob Watson.
There was always this guys,
we let go and you guys always sign it,
but I don't ever remember anybody.
You know,
even like an old Lou Pinella,
we never got anybody but got the old
Lou Panella or even like Mike Pack your
rule. Rick Sarone. It was really
an Indian like coming our way. We,
it always seems like they always end
up. Yeah. You might've got one guy,
Andy Hawkins,
who I remember the only Yankee,
and I remember he used to buy the helmets.
Carvel used to give an ice cream scoop
and the little mini batting hell,
I remember that.
Yeah.
And I used to watch the Yankee Games and
I'd write on the sticker and I put the
stats of the game on the back of a
sticker. I still have this one helmet.
Andy Hawkins threw a no hitter
and lost to the Chicago White Sox.
Five errors for walks. They lost
three nothing. He threw a no hitter.
You were at that game? No, that wasn't
that. I was watching with my law of Karma.
I think it was on the road
against the white sox.
And I think Hawkins ended up being a
red sock for like a half a season out of
the bullpen. If that sounds like
the kind of guy that we'd signed,
he throws a no hitter and he's seen
Lucille beliefs beliefs back then.
At least back then we did. But um, I
dunno, we're, we're, we're playing off.
I've got to tell you that Johnny
Damon went, that was, that was brutal.
And even though I know he was the one in
Kansas City and then he was in Oakland,
Oakland, then we got them. So I understood
there was just something about like,
we finally beat you guys and that he was
such like the poster child of our team.
And then just to watch him go get a
shave and a haircut like the ring,
like he was going over his parent's house.
He went corporate almost.
It's like was wild shy.
He who had the,
one of the better beards
in hair on the red sox,
like he had his beard was phenomenal
and he had like seven rbis in that game.
Seven you hit the Grand Slam. Yeah,
yeah, like seventh grade. So yeah,
that ruined it for me. Like that really
hurt the red sock. Yankee rivalry. Like I,
to me it I,
my fondest memory,
the ending would be like Pedro Martinez
throwing Don Zimmer on the ground.
That was the word that it was that for
me growing up, that was the height.
That was the height. Did that piss you
off when that happened or did you want to,
it made me so angry and then
let me ask you this Jerry. What?
What the fuck was he supposed to do?
He's got this old guy running at him.
Alright, he's got, these are his options.
Know when either he runs
away from an old guy. Okay,
that's one. Two, he punches
him in the face. Can't do that.
Can Not 10 not through that or you
gently take them by the side of his head.
I feel bad now because he just
passed away. I know I didn't.
He just sort of guide them to the ground.
That's what he did. I paid on Monday.
He was in a no win situation.
There's no way on earth.
He comes out of that where it's like
page or you did the right thing.
He had no shot.
He was the minute Zimmer planted his
feet and charged Pedro Martinez was in
trouble. Still was not a a
what's in it was not a good mom.
So then football where you're
going to football giants, giants,
congratulate giants.
I remember the greatest day of my life
was when the giants beat the nine,
as in the NFC championship game,
the Leonard Marshall sack knocked Montana
out giants when and how much and in
his career. And then my uncle took me
to see home alone in the movie theater.
Greatest Day of my childhood.
Do you know Paul Versey? You
got to meet him. You guys.
He opens for me. A lot of guys. I
definitely see. I definitely know I'd,
I'd definitely know him. You like Paul
Versey with hair? I just did that for him.
If he's listening. Um, uh, you know
what's funny, like back in the day, uh,
when entourage was first coming off of
people who don't know, uh, Jerry by,
by name, uh, he played
turtle on entourage.
Do you know I actually
auditioned for that? Did you
rip that turtle? That's, yeah,
that's how wide the casting net was
before they were throwing darts. Yeah. No,
and they got you a totally made
sense. But, um, yeah, I was, you know,
not like I'm good now, but I was
really bad at auditioning back then.
And that was, that was, it
was a memorable, awful one.
I can't remember cause it was so bad or
because the show went on to be a hit.
So there was like the
first season and a half,
I'm watching it going like God every
time they'd say your character's name and
be like, I would just sort of think
about that bad audition going out.
I haven't been back. I have
not been back since. But uh,
what's the deal with that man?
I got inflammation here that
maybe there's going to be a movie.
No, no, we just, we just
wrapped a movie a month ago.
We actually had to postpone
shooting Kevin Connolly,
one of the guys who
plays Eric on the shell,
broke his leg while we were
shooting, doing what? I was
kind of applied of it. Uh,
I've actually now told
the story a few times,
but it was a party scene
at the beach. And, uh,
we had a cameo from Russell
Wilson, so, and I knew,
I knew this was going to happen.
They wanted to do a little montage of us,
you know, playing a little tackle football
on the beach. And I begged, they said,
let's figure out what we're going to do.
Let's block it out a little
bit worse thing to do to,
to competitive below average athletically.
Guys see competitive day.
Oh yeah. Him and I is to say, Hey,
let's just turn the camera on and see
what happens. And sure enough, you know,
I go out, he drills me, he goes out and
attack on them. Like the third play.
It was actually the most harmless.
One of it all. I wrapped him up,
he like tried to dive and extend the
ball over the goal line and just his leg.
But we broke a broken two places.
Did you hear it? You heard it? Snap?
I heard something weird.
It wasn't like the Paul George awfulness.
It was not that, thank God. But uh,
I heard a little something. Did he,
did he, he didn't know. He popped up
and he thought he sprained his ankle.
Russell Wilson came over and said like,
you got the tie those laces tight. And uh,
he worked for like two days.
We're not knowing, just in,
finally he tapped as a guys, I gotta go,
I gotta go to a doctor and they x ray.
Like you have a broken fricking late.
He's in surgery the next day. What did he,
which, which bone,
fibula, fibula, surgeries,
screws and everything. So we got to
shut down from it, but the movie's done.
And I actually just saw an early
cut of it yesterday and it's,
it's actually good. Oh, I'm really
happy. I'm, I hate everything.
How do you deal with that
man? Like, uh, like I said,
the little stuff that I've done, I
immediately realized how little, uh,
just a little pow power you have
if you're just a performer. Like I
always hear a lot on set. Like, yeah,
it feels like it's going good. And then,
then there's always that. Yeah, man,
I hope to send comes together
because you have no idea. Um,
when you're doing it.
And I think more like the director
and the people who edit it,
they have an idea of the
direction it's going in.
But like I feel like if
you're just acting on it,
you kind of in this vacuum where you're
performing with the other people and
just hoping you're giving
them what they need.
I got a few things to say about that one.
I think it's like a game of opposites.
Anytime I've been on a set or we have,
whether it was like an
episode of entourage or even
a movie set of whatever it
is, when everyone's like, God, this
is great, this feels great, right?
Everyone's killing it. This is what
bill is killing it. Jerry's kill.
And then you watch it and it's Kinda eh.
And then I've been on set
where there's been times like,
I don't want to have any idea of this
shit's work is the weirdest shit we've
ever done. I, I'm like cross your fingers
and you watch it and it's the best.
It's great.
So you're not supposed to know.
That's the thing that's kind of
like in stand up the amount of time.
A lot of times you feel
like you're bombing,
then you get off stage
like God that sucks.
And then your buddies out in the crowd
going to people they would die laughing
because some nights you just can't,
you can't hear it. But I had an acting,
I have like a,
like I have total respect for uh,
any working actor cause that
just seems like the hardest,
I don't know how you guys get
to a point like how you get,
you get altitude in that career
because it's so fucking competitive.
Whereas like a comedian is difficult is
starting out is once you like build a
following, like say what have I went
to an Improv and I sold some tickets.
Like I don't have to re
audition now that's it.
At the next club it's like
okay this guy sells tickets.
So then you move up to this
next level and just, you know,
provided you keep getting
better, you know, you, you, you,
you have this thing and now you
have this thing like say, you know,
I go through you know,
periods without getting any acting work,
but I don't have to go back
to waiting tables and, and,
and all that type of stuff.
Did you go through a, uh,
did you have any like get something
really big early and then that just that
awful flatline for awhile.
My story is interesting and I'll give
you the quickest version possible,
but you know, I saw how sick are you
telling them? No, no. Everyone know,
a lot of people think like that.
I,
I kind of just showed up out here like
some meathead from Brooklyn and like got
cast Nataraj right away. It was, you
know, four or five years. Now look,
that's a short amount of time. It's
very quick scheme. But Tourney,
young and competitive, it
felt like an eternity. And I,
I lived in this and you know,
in Burbank for 10 years I
worked at every restaurant.
How old high when you came
out in 19 and I came out here,
I did like three episodes
of King of Queens. I'm like,
I'm staying as I never left. So you were
smart enough not to go to college? I did.
I did my six months at a,
at a college of Staten Island,
a very nice community
college back on the CSI.
He saying that big student allow colleges,
stupid Italians. We used to say, oh,
every kid who couldn't get into college,
they are now the schools.
It's actually a great community college.
I shouldn't really talk shit. But um,
I didn't have any great success.
I would always,
I would get an acting job that would
maybe last a month. I'd make like seven,
$8,000, which to me
was a million. Oh yeah.
And I quit whatever restaurant I where
I'd live off that for as long as I can.
And I just would go months without an
acting job and they'd go beg for my
waitering job back.
And that was my cycle for quite a while.
But even then, even though five years
is quick too, it's pretty quick.
But to go through that for five
years. I mean this, this time,
like you know what they talk about
New York. If I could make it there,
I can make it anywhere personally.
This town for me is just way,
way more like it's brutal
week. Yeah. And brutal.
I always feel like New York,
there's always like,
there's an excitement to
that city where out here,
I don't know if it's just the topography,
but this is like desolate out here and uh,
that sun beating down on you.
There's no change of season. It just feels
like groundhog day. Just every hog day.
Sunshine phone's not ringing. You know, I,
and I can't get anywhere in my car
when it's the, when it's great.
It's the best town to ever live in.
When it's bad.
It's probably the worst ever,
ever live in.
And I always tell people
I was not offended,
but like I've got a couple of people
in the last whatever year to be like,
what's like the easiest?
Well, how you get into acting,
like what's the easiest way?
I'm like the easiest way.
That's how you're going to add.
You're going to pose the co there is no
easy way and it's designed to make you
quit. The whole system is
designed to make you say,
I can't do this anymore. I'm going
home. It's made to make you say that.
Well, let me ask you
this, being also an, uh,
a transplant from the east coast to
you. Uh, do you miss these coast?
Do you see yourself ever going back?
Are you kind of settling in out here?
I've had, I've had a couple of
different trajectories with this.
In the beginning I hated La, you
know, meathead from Brooklyn.
My accent was 10 times
worse than it is now. Uh,
then I guess as I got a little
successful too, I got the hot,
the whole good side of the town. The
weather's great. I grew to love odes.
Unbelievable. It's, it's, it's great.
You and I sitting here and you're
getting an iced coffee with Ted's Cory.
It's great. It's great. Recently though,
and within the last year I've kind
of gotten to the place where I'm 30,
I'll be 35 soon. You know, my
family's all still back there.
My nieces and nephews are growing up now.
They're like, you know, six years old.
They're starting to get that age where
I could do stuff with them. Like I say,
maybe I don't need to be here
11 months, a year. Maybe it's,
maybe it's nine and maybe I'd
go to New York for two months.
I'm starting to get to that point.
Maybe I go spend some,
some more quality time elsewhere.
Maybe I don't need to,
I'm built up enough where,
look,
if I really blow it at this point
I'm going to have to have a serious,
serious problem. Must to happen. Right.
So maybe I go spend some
time somewhere else.
I'm at that point now it's research.
I'm always jealous.
Weird jealousy in New York guys. Cause
you can go back to your hometown and the,
and it's still a big industry town. You
can't come on, give me a little, I go,
I would go back to the suburbs
of Boston now. I know that
they shoot some stuff up there, but it's
just like if I went back there like, uh,
like,
you know,
what I really miss most about living
in Massachusetts is just going to a
sporting event where I'm
not in enemy territory.
It's like I left in [inaudible] 95 I was
in New York through the height of the
curse of the paid. All of that
has a bad run for you. Yeah, yeah.
It was all of that. And, and,
and Aaron Boone and Aaron Boone never
took hold because the very next year like
Aaron Boone probably,
it definitely would have been worse than
Bucky Dent had the next year not happen.
Right. But what happened was they just
sort of toward the bandaid off like,
oh my God, that sucked down. We
want it, thank God. But where the,
the Bucky dent the bill Buckner thing. It
just, it just, it just kept like, I'm a,
I remember we were like,
I was,
I had a warehouse job and it was like
two and a half years after the game and
just one day in the middle of the summer,
I was just sake shaking my head and my,
my boss was, well, what's the matter?
Like he thought the count was off
when I had a little of this truck.
I was just like, dude, I still can't
believe we fucking lost that series.
And he laughed. The ultimate
delayed, don't know. I mean I,
the reaction and all that,
but just like years later you
were just thinking about it.
So it was so, uh, like,
I mean, I imagined it as,
as much as oh four would suck for a Yankee
fan because of all that other success
you've had and then you won one
afterwards. It's bad, but it's not,
it's not as like a like take like,
you know, I guess, uh, I don't know.
Cleveland fans or something like that
where it's just like there's just no light
has been no light.
That's blip. But now, now
there's, there's not light,
but at least there's a little hole,
a glimmer of light as poke through it.
Lebron and maybe Johnny Manzel.
But yeah, it's been, I'm open.
I hope he's going to be good. I wanted
all, I'm, I'm a board. I think it's great.
It's the new era and there's
some dinosaurs that are
going to hate on him for
awhile.
I think there's nothing.
No. What about his size and those
guys? All those guys who run around,
first of all,
nobody's going to be faster and more
elusive at the quarterback position then
Mike Vick. So if, if, if he can
get caught, he can get hurt.
That's the only thing that I would worry
about. But a, I'm actually a browns fan.
Uh, I, I, my parents and some
other relatives who lived in Ohio.
Oh.
So you legitimately roof for the per my
girlfriend's from Ohio and I just went
there for the first time recently.
And they are the most passionate fans,
obviously Boston and New York too.
I'm all Boston teams by the of the crowd.
Couldn't believe
I liked the bronze cause
my dad liked the browns.
He grew up in Ohio and in Michigan,
so every year is going to be there a year.
So he went, he went to like all
municipal stadium, saw Jim Brown play.
That type of thing is amazing.
So he uh, he's got this weird,
I have this weird thing with him where he
was a tigers in a Cleveland browns fan.
So I have like,
uh,
an affinity for both of them and a little
bit with the Redwings if they're fans
weren't such dicks all the
time talking all this shit.
Granted they have all those cups,
but um, so I'm actually, uh,
I'm hoping that that he's going to,
he's going to, he's going to do well.
One of my prize followers.
Twitter. I'm not good on Twitter,
but Johnny Manzel follows me and that
was one of my prize follower. I'm,
I'm most proud of of that follow,
um,
where we actually,
me and my buddies when we went to go
see him last year to amazing rise to
Alabama when I was a fucking, it was a,
it was just a to go to a browns game.
I think I'm going to try to go October
12th. I think the plane is steel is,
I just want to go Whitney. I just
want to go see what that's all about.
Those fans.
I just can't believe how hard they show
up in route and they haven't won more
than five games and yeah,
that they're maniacs out there that you
would not want to walk out there with
the other person's no jerseys.
I'm going to go. Speaking of that,
how do you feel about like, uh,
attending sporting events out here in la?
I mean, I have, I personally,
I've not had the best experience
unless you show up wearing this shit,
which I'm never going to do.
I know I dress like a plain clothes
cop when I go to the game. Same here.
But like,
they just take it way too fucking
serious out here with is there's always a
little bit of that.
Uh,
you might get stabbed the
dodger games particularly,
or chargers. Oh, and they
just, shit I hear about like,
do some guy got shot at a fucking
40 niners Raiders preseason.
I've never gone to seasoned, get up
to any north kitten nor cal supports.
Like, I've never been to San Fran
yet since I've lived here. Oh, okay.
I've never been to oca. I need to
go. I want to go experience it.
The storied franchises
they have. Great. Yeah,
but you're not going into the black hole.
Lots of the Raider game wearing the
charger. Jai wouldn't, I wouldn't do that.
I wouldn't do that. Although
like I, I think the,
the rate of fence took a turn for the
worst when they started dressing up like
characters back in the day. The
crowding characters. Yeah. The crowd.
They all look like they were in
a biker gang and they would like,
legitimately scary. But now it's like, uh,
I'm not saying like there's a lot of
people in that stadium could fuck you up,
but you got that around the leak. But, uh,
until stupid characters man
with the spikes coming out,
they look like they should
be going to comic con.
They don't like the olive with the movie
weird science when like the motorcycle
gang comes in at the end, the CRAs
department, they look like those.
The guy that always struck me,
I saw a one shot of a guy who looked
just like one of the weird science biker
guys at the end. Jesus Christ. Or do you
just took my, now I went back outside.
I do. I've been watching a
lot of the old movies. Um,
well speaking of speaking
of movies, um, dude,
you're like insane shape right now and a,
and I'm obviously,
I asked you when you came
in the second you walked in,
I had down written down here that um,
you just signed on to
play two time world champ,
Arturo Gotti in an untitled biopic,
which I'm so site that they're making
this a executive produced by Mark Walberg.
And the second you came in, I was like,
Eh, you already shooting the movie.
You just see this training
at this point I'm,
I'm trained now and I'm kind of getting
ready. I'm, I'm not in the full swing yet.
Like we're actually going
to go have a training camp.
I'm going to go up to big bear and do
that whole like 24 seven thing. No women.
And they'll read it. I'm going to
do my best. I personally don't,
there's only a level of shred I can get.
Like there's a on the mid drift re region,
I'm Italian and from Ben also,
I was born hundred five pounds. I, we may
have to Cgi some shit with that. I Dunno.
But uh, how tall are you? Five seven.
If I have on good shoes.
And you were two oh five two
oh four. And what, what is,
what is the weight when
you went to the doctor,
why when you went to the document, you
have to have fire and he says, listen,
Jerry, I love the show. I'm
not trying to be a dick,
but you need to get down to
what we were supposed to be.
I'm not like the normal for my height.
Yeah.
One the normal from my height's one
50 I thought that would be a win.
What the 1950s one four
five six and a half.
He was like one 51 55 you'll be normal.
And that's actually
exactly how it happened.
I went to take a physical to go do a
movie where it's like the Hollywood
physical and make sure you're not dying.
They literally make sure your heart is
beating and that you don't have any weird
outward things.
I do the blood pressures and they look
in your ear like my mom could do that
physical for me if she had to and the guy
thought he was being real thorough and
like this guy is looking for
something to like fail me.
And he put me on the scale and I just
turned 30 it's like a week after my 30th
birthday and you know the doctor wasn't
trying to scam me. He's just like, look,
you're, you're not in any
physical threatening life
all during that. You're like,
you're, you're young still, but you
know what, as you get closer to 40,
if you go on this path, you're going to
be faced with some problems. So start now.
It's way easier now than when you're
going, when you're gonna be 39 frosting.
And I just started and, uh,
it's been four. I'm 30, I'm
going to be 35 now and I'm,
I'm at one 51. I'm in
that range of, I guess,
the proper way for my short ass.
All right,
Galatians do. And how long did it
take you to drop all that? Just,
it's just nonsense.
Still going on.
It's been years and you're doing it
the right way. You're gradually, uh,
did you do it more diet or,
or working out?
Both. Both. But I mean to, I, at the
time I was still smoking cigarettes.
Still a smoking pot still.
I quit all that.
Yeah. And that shit, by the way, I'm 46,
right around 40. Man. I'm telling you,
like there's this weird thing where at 40,
if you figured you started being
a knucklehead around 18, 19,
it does that tipping point where for
more your life you will be in a moron.
Then running around and riding your
bicycle as a kid out and all of that shit
that I'm telling you, it starts like the
sh the weight just fucking shut down.
And like, uh, all of a sudden,
just some of the conversations I'm having
with some of my friends, it's just a,
it's, it's what, what I mean,
unfortunately I never let
it get too out of control.
I'm about a buck 70 now. The worst I ever
did. I went about 20 pounds and dude,
it was all road. Fucking what? You
were up to one 91 I was almost closed.
I was closing on one 90. And
uh, this comic Keith Robinson,
I'm not going to say the
comics name that he called me,
but he was a redhead who was fat and
he called me him that day. And I,
and it just, it, it, it was funny as hell,
but it really stung me. And I was like,
all right,
I gotta go.
Cause they're one of the running jokes
on this podcast that I think fat shaming
works. If you're in a, like I'm,
I'm not trying to get in trouble
and we can comment already bullshit.
But it's just like I do that to myself.
Like I'll be looking in the mirror when
I'm just want to go look what you did,
you piece of shit. And I just said nobody
should love you. You know, just fucking,
it gets me like I just,
I just have an unacceptable wait.
Like I'm not fucking going past this
buddy. I have a, I have a photo
album in my phone that's like my,
my workout photo album. It's all
old photos. Right? That really a,
I look at it and it's not even cause I
want to look a certain way cause I look,
it's only, it's going to be what it is.
But I'm not a pretty boy. I, I'm not,
I'm not a hand, particularly
handsome guys. What it is
it here? Go Fuck Yourself.
You look great. I look at those two Oh
five things and that's where I'm like,
that shit ain't, it did like I don't
want to go to the gym that now.
Now we will you will,
you ought to shape as a kid or the no,
I mean that just happened
in your adult life.
I always like genetically we always
had like meat on our bones, you know,
we're short guys, even my brother too.
But like I plead every single sport.
I re,
I mean I,
there was not a day that went by in my
youth up until I moved out here that I
didn't do something that day.
Sports wise.
You know what's hilarious?
You probably the only guy who have a
moving out to la in show business and put
on weight. That's fun.
Unless you did it for,
I mean, God, I'm craft
service got me. I just went,
I went probably from 21 to almost 30
where I did not do shit except fuck.
I mean I work when I smoked and I AA.
That's all I did. So when you, uh,
how old were you when
you booked entourage?
23 going on close to 24
and that ran for what,
seven, eight seasons. Eight
seasons spanned across the IHB.
L does it with a year and a half break,
so spanned across a decade, you know,
basically, yeah, almost a decade.
10 Years of craft service. I mean,
that's understandable.
You kidding?
And then you start making
a little bit of money.
You could actually afford to take
a lady out for a meal. It's, yeah,
you went off the rails.
What you used to think was a good
restaurant and then all of it, you know,
I used to be like,
you know,
guy go into the ground round was like a
big group and then I made a little bit
of money then what I thought was a good
restaurant. And then the second, you know,
I met my wife. Then it's just like, yeah,
like Jesus Christ, so fucking kill me.
She,
she goes on the Internet and she knows
where all the places are and all that.
She's a foodie how she likes tonight.
Yeah. Yeah. He's an idiot. Yeah.
Until the bill comes and it's just like
Jesus just didn't break a window if not
fucking worth runoff. We, yeah, we
went out the other and every once,
like once a month I go out and I and I,
uh,
will go out and it'll be just like some,
yeah, it's fucking brutal. They gave,
you can tell every stutter and we just
went out to a steak place the other night.
It was fucking delicious,
but the bill was
really annoying. Really to add to
people is like two 80 something.
There was, it was brutal.
It was brutal. And
I then I bring it up to her. I think
I brought it up to her. She got mad,
said it was tacky
when I was in Ohio,
when I was just in Ohio.
We went to a really nice restaurant and
uh, we went to the bar first and the,
or the round the drinks. So like four of
us and you know, I get the credit card.
I only had like 20 byline, like
20 bucks on me, my credit card.
It's like go and I'm waiting.
I'm like,
God is going to be a credit card
situation came $16 for like five drinks.
I'm like, oh my, Geez,
what it should be la women's 6,000
a $60 drink water at the minimum.
And I'm not a cheap guy,
but it,
that was [inaudible] that
used to be dive bars out here,
but all the fucking hipsters,
they take over every one of them.
Now the dive bars are more expensive,
upscale bars. Brutal. It's brutal. So I'm,
I want to make sure that I
don't, uh, I don't forget to
promote everything. So, uh,
let me this, this is, this is
actually just for me because, uh,
like I was saying earlier,
just as far as how you make
money outside of this business,
I just think that gives you such an
unbelievable amount of power where if you
have this income coming in, if the acting
work slows down just for a little bit,
like when they come at you and you know,
with the movie where
you got to be in drag,
you only have to do it if you
want to. Yeah. We're like,
you see a lot of these
guys now because uh,
I guess it's more before we talk
about the fat cells thing, like, um,
in your time in the movies,
like the last 10 years in the mood,
like the whole movie
industry now with the, uh,
I'm not even gonna say the name of the
websites. We can watch it for free.
It's like it's doing to the
movie business. What happened
to the music business?
100%. Yeah. So now like for you know,
people outside the business
listening right now,
basically how it works now is
who is that have the best chance,
correct me if I'm wrong or like low
budget independent things or those hundred
million dollar robot superhero movies.
The in between,
which is all the movies that we
probably grew up loving, you know,
the standby me's,
those coming of age kind of move.
Those in betweens are almost not obsolete.
Like we don't enjoy them,
but studios aren't making them right
cause they're businesses like two,
$3 million or less or a
hundred million or more.
And that in between gap is actually
proving not to be the least profitable
business. And I think those are the
better movies personally. But uh, you're,
you're absolutely hit the
nail on the head. Yeah.
Cause I was sitting there one night and
I saw like the probably like the 15th a
list movie star signed
on to do a TV series.
That's probably why all these TV series
is so unbelievable now. It's like,
it's like, it really is like the
second golden age of television.
Like some of the stuff that's out
there and I'm really far behind.
People keep telling me I got to see Fargo
and there's a, I'm where I'm reformed.
I'm on like season three of breaking
bad or you what's how far behind I am or
yeah. And like season one, a house
of cards. I'm real behind. Yeah.
I started watching the killing.
I like that. What's the
first two seasons of that?
A house of cards. I watched the first
episode, I was like, I love this.
And then you know, my life got busy
and I haven't got back to that.
So pay attention for that one.
You can't, I'm like, yeah,
the popcorn and you got to let
you got to lock in on that one.
You can't really casually watch
house of cards. Absolutely.
So all these guys now you see like,
I mean you see half the cast of like a
boogie nights and all these movies I love,
they're all um, on, on TV now. So,
um, with it change in like that,
that's why I'm, I love this,
this move. I mean, and,
and you did the most riskiest thing is
essentially opening a restaurant, right.
And, uh, how did the, how did that all
come about? It came about because the, uh,
the Sao of facts,
owls is a real guy.
He's one of my best friends
I know from New York. Uh,
we always talked when we were young,
young, I'm talking 20 years old out here.
Like we need like an east
coast kind of place out here.
We didn't know what it was. And then
obviously, you know, he, and he's not,
he wasn't in the entertainment business.
So He's a mechanical engineer,
like builds buildings. And uh, he
kind of ended that part of his career.
And Him and another friend of mine came
to me with this whole plan. And look,
I don't know,
I'm like Paulie in Goodfellas.
Like I don't know anything about the
restaurant business. Right, right.
I really genuinely, no, I don't cook.
I don't want to sit down and I eat.
It's exactly how that conversation went.
And you know, I, they,
they played another one it down someday
and sound's going to be a fucking jail.
Could show fuck you pay me.
No.
So I just, I invested in the two of them.
I said, guys, I don't know about food.
I know all restaurant, most restaurants
fail. But um, not that I feel like I owed,
but like if I can empower
one of my best friends,
cause I'm a lucky motherfucker right
now, if I can't give her a shot, why not?
I went into it saying I'm
going to lose every dollar. I,
so I wrote a check that I was
comfortable losing every cent of right.
And sure enough, the kid came through and
I look, I don't run the business right.
I'm not going there and making
sandwiches. I, I'm in on everything.
I know what's going on.
But they run that show and they were,
we just opened our fourth one in Austin,
Texas through,
you've got to update your
bio. You're killing it so
much. They told me you had a,
you had two locations, now
you've got four. Well you got to,
you had to be comfortable with if your
buddy knew how to build and design a
building that he could make a sandwich.
You mean, that's gotta be a joke. Yeah.
But he also built out the places because
of his background and the other guy,
Josh of fat Sal's who he's the one
that they came up with the were making
sandwiches over here. Right. You know,
he's been in the food industry his whole
life. So they were the team and I said,
I'm,
I'm betting on you guys because the first
one was at Ucla Westwood function and
I said, they have a great way of making
everyone feel like it's your spot.
Like you're a VIP.
I'm like,
these kids are gonna are gonna come to
hang out with you too. And sure enough,
I hate to say I told you
is I was right about that.
And then they took it from there. And
if just did you guys with that, uh,
that flooded, did anything come down your
way? Not Luckily, not ours, but I mean,
we certainly felt some of the effects
of it, but it didn't, it didn't hit, uh,
our spot. But, um, for people
listening, uh, all over,
there was a water main
break. Crazy, crazy.
Like one of those 10 foot pipes you
could drive a truck through. Yeah. Uh,
broke in, you know, it's not no big deal.
We just steal the water
here things and you know,
we have so much water in anyway.
So tell, tell me about this.
I'm, I'm jumping all around.
I'm scatterbrained here,
but um, so this Arturo
Gotti movie, uh, now is,
is this is going to be, uh,
it's going to go all the way.
Obviously you're going to go to the,
I don't want to ruin the end of the movie,
but I know how his life and, and, and,
and that should stay sorta like
open ended as to whether was it was,
it officially ruled like a suicide.
It was officially real a suicide.
Arturo Gatti, uh, at the,
after he retired,
you know,
he went to Brazil and
with his wife at the time,
they would go and sit and the kid and,
uh, he was found dead and the government,
their view ruled it, it was
ruled a suicide. She was,
his wife was actually in jail on trial
for the murder and she was not guilty
acquitted. And now she's
back here. Um, you know,
while we will not be able to literally
make the movie and say she killed him,
the goal of the movie
without giving away all,
all too much is if we tell
this guy's story correctly,
you as an audience member will be
able to walk out saying, does no,
no fucking way. He hung himself
with a pocketbook strap from the,
the staircase and ended up
under the island of the kitchen.
Like I have the reports,
it is mind blowing the,
the way they say it went down.
Um,
so this movies being made because his
longtime manager to Pat Lynch, great guy,
he's actually in the documentary
a lot. Uh, the w Gaddy Ward Tail,
the Hbo Documentary, that
Walberg Voiceover. And um,
the last man was that last century was
already the 90s, like [inaudible] 98. No,
I think it was there. It was early
2006, 2002 was the first fight.
And I remember I watched that fight live
was at Mohegan Sun, 2000 people there.
And Jim Lamp, we actually says in
the fight, man, he's like, man,
I bet you these 2000 people
did not realize they were
walking into and maybe the
best fight they'll ever see when
you were like, no, no he can't.
He was commentating the fight and he
was just saying he's looking around the
small little arena. 2000
peoples. I bet the 2000 pumps.
Are you watching it and I'm on a big
screen or you're at the front cause
Washington at home. Oh, okay.
Here probably on break from
working in Boston market stone,
probably watching the fight with
some Mac and cheese and um, you know,
some mark played Micky ward in the
fighter and it's a great, great movie.
And I love Mickey Ward as well.
And you know,
they weren't at a place really to
get into the gas rewards stuff.
So I think this is kind of,
that's why I think that's why mark wanted
to be involved is that's the next step
is showing that bromance, the ultimate
bromance of a Touro and Micky ward.
Right. And there's all those movies,
uh, boxing movies is, it's just,
I mean I'm a sucker for those. That to
me that's like the modern day western.
Like when I was a kid I Stories Watch
westerns with my dad cause he loved those.
And then I look at the rocky movies,
they started off good,
they got a little stick out, a little
crazy. But, but you know what's,
what was cool about the rocky,
all of them was the premise of each.
Like I, I love, I can't even
remember which one. There
was so many. I'm an expert.
Will talk to me. I got the Rusch one
was on that was a little ridiculous,
but the one where he's coming back
like he's lost all his money, uh,
that it's rocky five,
five Tommy Morrison.
Yeah.
And that what I loved about that,
I'm not saying you know when it
goes back to Philly. Yeah. And what,
and what I love about is just
the premise of it that they,
they age the character with Stallone.
Like I thought they did a really good
job and they kind of did like a good
trajectory of it.
I'm not saying the executed,
this is what you gotta do nowadays
because there's so many fucking people out
there that are going to take,
well you actually think
that's a good fucking morning.
I'm just saying like what the jump off
point for where they were going with that
too. That's hilarious.
You watched all of those.
Let's also take a moment and
realize one thing about how crazy,
how far we've come.
If we tried to make rocky one now at the
love story part where rocky and rocky
essentially rapes Adrian
when he has her at the house.
She tries to get out. He slams the
door and I need the famous shit.
Like he puts his arms up on the pipe and
the wife via, you won't let her leave.
She's trying to leave. She's
like, let me go. And he's
like, no, you will. You Go, no,
you got us. He basically date
rapes 80 doesn't let her leave.
There's a lot of that.
It's like, dude, let her go
that, uh, back in the day, I guess
I shouldn't be laughing at this.
It's just fucking, uh, just
the fact that that one,
what it wants,
we want you won the Oscar did it also
when I think it won best picture,
best screenplay at, yeah. It was almost
a sweep. Jesus Christ. I forgot. Oh,
I thought that all that
shit was in the [inaudible].
Are you a set that little sports holy
itself where they'd slap the shit out of
him? Like I thought that
that was just in the 50s.
You a sports movie guy or now
some of them I like an I is,
if they're done in a way,
uh,
if they're not too cliched at this, it's
very hard at this point now it's like,
it's almost impossible. I didn't, uh,
I'll have issues like say that movie Rudy
loved the story, loved and all of that,
but when you saw the actor they picked
and then the end they showed the real guy,
you saw the real guy. And even though
he's small, you look at him like, dude,
that guy's a fucking animal man.
I would not want that guy running at me.
Like I can see how that guy had
a heart of a lion, but just,
you know,
hard.
I would have fought if they were making
that movie right now to play Rudy. I, we,
I live in meeting Sean Aston head to
head battle. I would have, oh my lord,
I would just say your rights
for that movie. Absolutely.
Nowadays nowadays they're not.
That would be your one cycle I go is
Rudy every Halloween? That's my house.
When I get to put on Notre Dame Jack and
I hold a Bible. No you don't. Yes I do.
Ah Ha's my goto that and
Schneider from one day at a time.
Dude, see you. So you basically you
love acting the way I love stand up
100%.
Like I don't know about you,
but acting was just my
way into movies and TV.
I didn't know I could have easily been
an editor and I would have been almost
equally as happy.
Yeah.
I wouldn't have had a of cool
stories that I have now would acting,
but it was something in, in
TV or movies, whatever it was.
I just enacting was what that landed on.
Oh, speaking of that type of stuff, uh,
meeting all these people, uh, all those
years on all those seasons on entourage.
Who was your favorite guest star? Cause
you guys had some monsters on that show.
God, it's real. And I know people
always try to take a high road.
I didn't want to single out one person.
I'm not doing that handful, whatever.
Give me, I mean, I love,
I love James Cameron only because I think
he like legitimize the fake world that
we created. Like James Cameron on the
show was directing Aquaman. And so he,
like when he came on, he legitimize our
fake world are fake universe. But, uh,
I mean,
I loved like Bob Saget.
We had the whole cast full
house at one point a dice.
We had dice on their dice
was race was phenomenal. And,
uh, I never viewed, told me when I was
a little kid sneaking the dice tapes,
when my brother listening to him
that'd be acting when Andrew dice clay,
I would've punched him in the nuts.
Now people don't understand like
the impact that guy, how I learn.
I saw dice clay at the Worcester Centrum.
This is like where like the Celtics
could have done a home game too.
I was like second to last row in the
upper deck and he came out and destroyed.
And in the end he did his
impressions and then I swear to God,
he played a drum solo.
I'm not even lying like this.
It was like he could do no uh,
no wrong.
And it's so hard now with all the internet
and all the fucking podcasts and all
of this shit for somebody to have
an impact and get that big and uh,
that's one of the, his son is one
of the best drummers I've ever seen.
Son Max you talked about you guys,
he told me his son is
on real on the drums.
Like well knock your head off
with the drums fit. There you go.
So we had an appointment. You
had so many cool. I mean the,
I always describe it like this.
Like we had one day on entourage where
I don't think any other show would ever
do this on the call sheet.
You 6:00 AM call at 6:00 AM we
were working with Sydney Pollack,
great actor, director, and then after
lunch or doing a scene with Kanye west,
it's like wherever are you
going to do in one day?
Are you going to do scenes with Sydney
Pollack in the morning and Kanye West in
the afternoon. It was, that was the one
of the coolest parts of that. So awesome.
How crazy is that Bob Saget. I
love him. I'm obsessed with him.
And he did something really cool. My
nephew, who's now watching full house,
my mom bought them all the DVDs. It's his
favorite show is five years old. He, he,
he wants to call me uncle
Jesse. He asked me, he's like,
I call you uncle Jesse instead of uncle
Jerry. Yeah, sure. So I tweeted that.
And Bob who, uh, Bob's facade,
he must follow me and the
row like DM me. Like, look,
if the kids ever in town bring him the
fat Sal's, I'll come me. And like Bob,
if you, if my nephew sees
the real you, he might,
you might see a first five year old heart
attack. I might just fall on the floor.
So I did a benefit was Saget
la last week and that guy,
he's out of his fucking mind.
He goes on stage and he starts wishing
the disease we're trying to stop.
He's wishing the disease on the club
owner and it's the funniest like five
minutes I've seen in a while.
And the crowds all like uncomfortable
in scorm is of course a couple of people
that get it, that he's just joking around,
but he goes up and he, it's fucking,
he just goes up and rifts.
So he'll talk himself into
a hole and he just, no,
he just keeps digging it. He doesn't try
to get out. He tries to, EIT goes out,
he tries to dig all the way through and
come out the other side down in China.
And that's what he did. He felt
them going and he just kept, he's,
he's out of his mind. This
was one of my favorite, um,
comics to watch because of that style.
And then also because of all the people
that watched full house and they still
think there's going to be this America's
funniest home. Yeah. But this guy, this,
that, yeah. This family sort
of like entertainment kind
of thing. Quick Bob thing.
And Doug Allen actually
said the creator of honor.
I said this on my podcast when, when
you went to Bob Saget to do the shell,
Doug wanted to play Bob as like broke,
like broke,
like live in somewhere and
blah. And Bob's like, Look Doug,
I'll do any one thing I won't
do. I won't play broke. Right.
Because I d I won't play. So Doug
was like, all right, well what about,
what would you like to have
sex with prostitutes? It's
like, yes, he died easily,
but I won't play Bro. He would
not play down on his luck.
Broke Bob. But he's like,
I love, yeah, why not? I'll have sex
with prostitutes. Yeah, of course.
Because he just, he just thought
it was a, they want to do it.
That was like his one. I'm not
playing bro. Cause that like, um,
it just doesn't fit with what I do.
That's also,
that's probably a smart move too because
it's so many people would think that he
actually did that where if you
just do the prostitute thing,
like as soon as comedy a little bit. I
guess like in if you, if you know him,
you know,
you don't really take that seriously,
but you may be kind of wonder in
the back of your mind like, wait,
maybe now he's great, you know? Oh Jesus,
all these memories are coming back. I,
I was,
uh,
I was walking my dog and there's a
house that I walked by that you guys,
I didn't even realize I was watching a
rerun and you guys shot without Ralph
Macho there. Oh God. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yes, yes. I'm Dylan too.
Yeah, that goes. Um, and of course,
you know, Ralph was hilarious and uh,
every time I swear to God, like I, I've
walked by that thing like 15 times.
Every time I go by it. Like nine
times out of the 15, I'll be like,
we asked them to do the [inaudible] stood
right in the best way to do the crease.
Shut us down on the crane
kick. What does that, oh,
the famous Daniel Larusso crane chick at
the end that he hits January. We said,
well, you do the cranky. He's
like, no, I won't do it. And
you only asked once, right?
Oh yeah, yeah. Out The respect. Of
course he asked me once, he says no, we,
we really tried to never make anyone
uncomfortable view if a cameo came on,
like they really had control of
what, how far they want it. Yeah.
It was never done with like,
you're in on the joke.
We're not trying to make
you look like a dick if,
if you're uncomfortable either don't
do it or we'll change it. Doug,
Doug was always great about that. That's
awesome. Well, I, I had an awesome time.
A finally getting me, I know
I met you briefly, but uh,
I'm really happy for
all your success here,
but we didn't really get to talk
too much about your podcast. What's,
is it just you? Is it going to be like
another, uh, it's, it's just me, but I do,
I do have guests, uh, a lot of the
heavy sports gunky guesses. You know,
I'm trying right now not to, because it
is the dog days of summer and you know,
there's no football, there's
no hoops. So I'm real.
I'm every time I every show at some
point I say I'm not going to talk about
supports because the minute,
you know October comes around,
it's probably going to transition
into that a lot. Oh absolutely. So,
but we're doing some fun sports things.
Uh, we got like the Sports Academy Awards.
I'm doing this one thing where we're
going to like do the best sports movies
never made so, and I want my
audience cast. Listen to that.
Well I would love for you,
I'd love to get your take on this too.
Don't we're going to cast the
86 mets that move. Oh Geez.
Let's cast. But I'm dumb. Say
I'm doing that one on the,
on the shell next week. I think when
we cast the 86 mets, little teaser,
you know Darryl pardon himself,
he was a little younger,
would have been a great Darryl strawberry.
I got the best dow strawberry who
is a little teaser with this way.
To me it's a genius call.
I don't know how you're going to react
and only because of what he looks like
now.
Okay.
Dave Chappelle is dow strawberry
cause he's chat right now has a knee.
The pictures I've seen of Chappelle,
he's like, yeah, yeah, huge.
I saw Seattle. He is, he's like a big boy.
I can see him cross the room at this
point. I would cast him as Dao. Oh.
But we get, have fun with
it. We could have, I mean,
Lenny Dykstra who's going to play Lenny
Dykstra Mooky Wilson, Dwight Gooden,
Sherry Carter on the Hernandez. He's
bringing up some bad memories. You know,
I wish we wish we didn't
play them in 86 his,
I really would have enjoyed that team
more because I saw so many things on that.
Just the unbelievable like this, the
level of talent that was on that team was,
was, was insane. And uh, you know,
obviously what happened when we ran,
until we had those fuckers beat, uh, that
book too, if you ever want to read it.
I watched that so little, I don't
even remember the names. Like,
I can't even remember who was the guy
who ran across the home plate and he put
his hands on his helmet like Lima Zilly.
Why did I think it was night?
I'm thinking maybe it was,
maybe it was night. My initials.
Mine is telling me Mozilla, but
that's not a fact. So the hind,
the bag Wagner had everything fucking
show that forever. It may be nice,
still love Vin Scully,
but every once in a while
when I'm watching the Dodgers
game listening to him,
he was,
his voice will get up into that register
and that's all I'm sure you imagine if
that APP and now with social media,
what the hell that would that would
set social media break Twitter if that
happened right now Twitter would
have to shut down there, whatever.
I don't know anything about technology,
but whenever they use that shit would
break. If bill Buckner happened right
now. Oh, and he like bill Buckner and
actually back then before social media,
he had to leave. Yeah.
Boston. And He, you know,
he was upset and he talked about it too.
And I was kind of like a,
I felt bad for him on one level, but
on another level it's like, dude,
you know what? What do you eat?
We haven't won it. And this long.
What'd you think was going to happen?
It, it hit a pebble or something.
I don't know. It's like, but you know when
it's a little slow roller, what do you,
what do you think? Did he
expect compassion? I don't know.
Did He really expect compassionate?
I know you,
she gets compassion for his fucking Bob
Stanley. That's who should give him,
he said,
son,
I'm a fucking card every week that he took
that off of him or whoever was, I see.
I haven't literally have never, I
never watched the game again. Go.
There was no reason to go there.
One time I watched some highlights and
we had that Calvin Sheraldi in there and
it was just single single, single,
don't go through it. It was,
it was the sickest day to start
getting cold sign on and no,
but it's fine because we won all
these championships, but it's,
there's just something about that
one. That one hurt. That was,
cause I was 18 when that happened.
That's when bill Buckner happened.
I was 10, so I didn't even, I mean,
I didn't even know that we had one
at that long and I didn't even,
I knew the Yankees had won
some championships, but I
was too young to get it.
But by [inaudible] 86, I
got it. And uh, you know,
you'd think the Celtics won it that year.
Patriots went to the Superbowl,
we got the shit kicked out of us,
but it was looking good for we've,
that was foreshadowing are this, this past
tenure. We kind of got it all at once,
but um, but anyways, hey, I'm,
I'm really happy for you man.
To all the success in like in the
highest compliment mount of, you know,
back in the day, you know, it
was, it was really hard to,
to go from a television show where
he was so known as a character,
especially if they had like a nickname
or something like that to then to be
going on to doing the stuff to get to
when you're playing this Arturo Gotti,
I think it's going to lead to great
things. You've got all these sandwiches,
places you could kill an end.
You've got a podcast and I'm helping
you promote it on my own podcast.
She wants about bad for fucking
business. That right there. I cannot
thank you enough though for having me.
I've been a, I've been a fan for quiet.
I actually, when I, when I met
you that night, the nic screening,
we saw a screening for the
Knicks. Val Is, Oh, I, uh, uh,
Michael Michael Rag Rappaport still need
directed and which is great by the way.
It's, it's awesome. What's it called
again? Uh, when the garden was Eden. Yeah.
Which is based on a book,
right? It's based on a book.
When the Knicks were actually good, which
I don't know. See, it's similar to you.
Like you're, I'm like that
with the Knicks. Even like,
I just have no idea that they're just
losers to me. But you weren't sure.
We'll know for Pat Riley those, the
early enough, but yeah. Well, you know,
losing game game six and sevens and the
rock is, John's stock's going to for 17.
The joke was John Stocks start to shoot
himself after the game, but he missed, oh,
you know,
it was a,
that was my gen Patrick Ewing missing
the finger or Reggie Miller scored eight
points and 20 sound. I feel your pain. Oh,
sorry. But I'm glad I want to be your fan
long enough. You got those fucking scam.
So yeah. But anyways, I hope,
uh, what little I could
do on this podcast, I hope
makes bad for business. Uh,
a big hit out there and uh,
congratulations on this.
A Turo gaudy thing, man.
I can't wait and I'm going to hit,
you're a fat cells pretty soon. Oh,
you're a VIP now bill. All right, Jerry.
Thanks a lot, man. Thanks man. Alright.